vous allez avoir une interview cauchemar
on ne bouge pas pendant le génial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien internes ou cauchemar
qu'elle pourrait être pour vous
salvatore adamo le pire des accidents
conjugaux vous faire surprendre par
votre femme quand vous êtes avec votre
maîtresse
surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleure amie ou troisième solution
surprend
votre femme et votre maîtresse
oui je pense que ce serait su reprendre
ma femme dans les bras des meilleures
amies ouais ben oui ça serait le pire je
pensais qu est le pire cadeau qu'on
puisse vous faire une perceuse sans fil
un abonnement dans un club de gym ou le
nouveau cd d'un à rieux par exemple
aulas une perceuse sans fil
la pire situation au quotidien pour vous
c'est d'avoir une cigarette mais pas de
feu d'avoir une carte bleue mais pas de
code ou d'avoir une fille canon mais pas
de préservatif allez la dernière quand
même j'avertis ma femme que tout ça est
théorique n'est ce pas ouais ouais c'est
ce que voulait dit en rentrant
voici tu vas trouver ton meilleur ami à
dire que ces théories qui est alors à
une perceuse sans fil
quels correctifs pour vous la pire des
illusions apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans casimir
non thierry lafond mettait des
chaussettes dans son collant
que goldorak et doublé pour les cascades
awk chirac est mêlé à la sphère des hlm
de la ville de paris non je pense que
comme je crois encore au père noël
apprendre d'un coup qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans casimir ça roule vers ce serait ma
fille
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui est pire pour vous un
portable qui sonne tout le temps qui
sonne jamais
à qui sonne jamais ben
oui merci le pire c'est de grandir seul
de vivre seul ou de vieillir seul
je pense que c'est vieillir seul à avoir
connu la compagnie et puis se retrouver
seul parce que si on grandit seul on a
le temps de s'y habituer
on ne bouge pas pendant le jean galle
[Musique]
le pire des accidents conjugaux
est-ce que ça serait pour vous de vous
faire surprendre par votre femme avec
votre maîtresse
de surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleure amie
ou de surprendre votre femme avec votre
maîtresse attitrée vers
presse de surprendre ma compagne a mis
ses seuls pire je crois que ce serait le
pire effectivement deux personnes qu'ils
aiment d'un coup là d'un coup je suis
la pire situation pour vous quotidien
c'est d'avoir des cigarettes n'est pas
de feu
une carte bleue mais pas le code ou une
fille canon et pas de préservatif
alors je fume pas vous fumez vous êtes
le père qui fumé des cigarillos vous
êtes dégoûtés du tabac ce qui est
complètement c'est irrémédiable donc je
crois qu une carte bleue sans que ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ce qu'ils
soient bien à la ville qu'à non plus
mais non c'est pas ça mais ça je pense
qu'on peut s'arranger
la pire des illusions pour vous c'est de
savoir qu'il ya quelqu'un dans casimir
que thierry la fronde avait des
chaussettes dans son collant frédéric ce
que goldorak et doubler dans les
cascades ou les tiberi peuvent s'en
sortir
alors que les tiberi puisse s'en sortir
ce serait pas une désillusion parce que
ça me paraît assez évident mais alors
que thierry la fronde émis des
chaussettes ça alors là ce serait une
catastrophe le pire pour vous le pire
cauchemar c'est que votre portable sonne
tout le temps ou jamais tout le temps à
ça c'est un supporter un insupportable
ce serait pire pour vous d'être sdf ou
d'habiter dans une maison hantée
sdf mais pire ça serait de connaître à
l'avancé le jour de votre mort ou
d'ignorer que vous êtes atteint d'un mal
incurable
je parle la mort me fait pas peur ça me
paraît quelque chose de normal enfin je
veux dire donc
oui oui
vous fait peur vos michel a vu
le pire pour vous ce serait de ne plus
pouvoir toucher votre femme ou de plus
vouloir la touche et vouloir le pire ça
serait de vivre sous terre après une
catastrophe nucléaire où de devoir vivre
en orbite après un cataclysme écrit tu
sais que je reçois un cyclothymique
il a les guides dix voiliers chaleur
démoraliser les deux situations je crois
que ça serait quand même
la première hypothèse parce que là ça
sera vraiment les conséquences dans
l'état du maine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interview cauchemar terrible vous allez
voir c'est terrible on va commencer avec
les accidents conjugaux ce qui serait le
pire pour vous ça serait de vous faire
surprendre par votre femme avec votre
maîtresse
de surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleur pote
ou de surprendre votre femme votre
maîtresse ensemble
je pense que ça va être mon pote huawei
alors si vous sur ce point c'est
terrible pour moi je pense que je vivrai
mal quoi ouais je sais où aller je sais
pas ben justement je préfère pas le
savoir le pire cadeau qu'on pourrait
vous faire
des vacances avec jean marie bigard
un concert de chants classiques avec
lambert wilson et
wii party tour des quais avec
je n'ai révisé les sépare
le concert
mais bon c'est la pire situation ce
serait d'avoir un pétard mais pas de feu
aller parce que la réunion quoi
s'appelle réunion les annales zamar
zamar mal zamal oui je fais si j'y
retourne faut que je me remémore la tête
parce que sinon je
demande
c'est qu'il m'avait appris ça en fait
c'est thierry jean-pierre le juge
jean-pierre il est de la réunion peu
zamal il m'avait expliqué ça alors donc
pires situations un pétard mais pas de
feu une carte bleue mais pas de code ou
une fille mais pas de préservatif
une fille préservatif c'était ça serait
terrible moi je pense ne s'use pas sans
cependant non
elle est très plaisir 26 ans déclare
alors très très très très préservatif le
pire c'est un portable qui sonne tout le
temps ou un portable qui sonne jamais
rien comme jamais jamais et vous
mais on n'a pas d'amis le pire c'est le
portable lambert wilson bonnes réponses
le pire pour vous ce serait d'être sdf
ou d'habiter dans une maison hantée par
un collant du xviiie siècle du sdf alors
le pire ce serait de connaître à
l'avancé le jour de votre mort ou
d'ignorer que vous êtes atteint d'un mal
incurable
moi je préfère ignorer le 6 mai on est
venus tous atteints d'un mal incurable
puis ça va tous mourir oui le 200 oui
c'est vrai
et le ce qui est génial c'est qu'on sait
pas quand ouais moi si tu me dis c'est
dans une demi heure j'ai peut-être
quitter le plateau pour aller boire une
bière
pas forcément rester ici
le pire ça serait plus vouloir toucher
votre femme ou plus pouvoir la toucher
plus pouvoir
le pire ça va bientôt être fini
le pire c'est de grandir seul de vivre
seul ou de mourir seul
je voudrais mourir seul c'est le pire ça
moi je prends soin moi je crois que j'ai
vraiment plombé la durance la non 1g
plomber l'ambiance là il faut un petit
peu de la forêt il faut un petit coup de
là pour m'aider
rouget
c'est la révolution
je resterai imperturbable alors
interview cauchemar le pire cadeau qu'on
pourrait vous faire ça serait de vous
envoyer en vacances avec ma mère ou avec
ma mère
avec votre mère ou père soit il peut
faire partie avec ma mère qui l'a jamais
vu j'ai quand même soixante dix ans ma
mère va on a toujours des surprises
prochaine mais surprise qu'elle a prêté
de [ __ ] vas-y c'est sa mère
la pire des situations ça serait d'avoir
un pétard mais pas de feu une carte
bleue mais pas de code ou une bimbo mais
pas de capote
à un pétard et pas de feu ouais c'est
bien la pire des illusions ça serait
d'apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un dans
casimir que thierry la mort de thierry
d'apprendre habille les chaussettes dans
son collant que goldorak et doublé pour
les cascades ou que ma mère fait plus
que vous dans les sondages c'est la
première à breaker le pire c'est un
portable qui sonne tout le temps qui
sonne jamais qui sonne tout le temps
le pire ce serait de connaître à
l'avancé le jour de votre mort ou
d'ignorer qu'il est atteint d'un mal
incurable
c'est dur pour moi le pire ça serait
d'ignorer le jour de la mort c'est pas
ça la question oui mais bon des deux je
sais ce sera donc la 12e qui est le plus
proche donc ça serait quoi ma d'ignorer
que je suis à non ignorait que
j'aimerais vous engueuler chance après
on s'il vous plaît
avant par les boulonnais jean galle
je vais parler
reparler par bon nombre comme en cent
d'accès
c'est bon tu sais tu es tu as raison
mais je suis comme ça mais je n'ose pas
des fois en fait tu fais pas du favori
qui gérait bien on va le refaire c'est
un genre d'objets de leur faire il a il
a parlé ont valu
attention
on ne couche ma pendant le train de
courir le bouchon ne bouge pas pendant
le signal
le coach m'a abandonné dingle voilà un
séduisant c'est plus propre
bien alors voilà donc la table ou
cauchemar le pire truc hein le pire des
accidents conjugaux c'est de vous faire
surprendre par votre amant avec un autre
de surprendre votre amant avec votre
meilleure amie sinon le le pire
cauchemar c'est de trouver la personne
que l'on aime entre andry ravec
quelqu'un d'autre à 30 coucher ouais bon
c'est pas très grave ces bonnes réponses
[Applaudissements]
et vous jamel
et vous arriver de pire c'est de vous
faire surprendre par votre amant avec un
autre but de surprendre votre amour avec
votre meilleure amie
et moi on ne marche pas avec vous le
pire cadeau qu'on puisse vous faire une
perceuse sans fil des vacances avec
vanessa paradis ou l'intégrale de y'a
pas photo en vidéo
l'intégrale de y'a pas photo
ça va loin
la pire situation dans laquelle vous
pourriez vous trouvez pascal sevran
avoir une cigarette mais pas de feu une
carte bleue mais pas de code un mec
sublime mais pas de préservatif
se doutait bien qu'avec vous
c'est le service public en même temps je
me dis ah oui c'est ça c'est le service
public cigarettes et pas de feu ouais
c'est une version à vous pour gens c'est
ça que j'aurais dit un pétard mais pas
trop
non lui sait pas il les avale les
joindre
la pire des illusions ça serait
d'apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un dans
casimir
que thierry la fronde a mis une
chaussette dans son collant
ou que chirac est mêlé à la sphère des
hlm de paris que thierry la fronde a mis
les clarets
le pire c'est un portable qui sonne tout
le temps qu'ils savent jamais assez un
portable qui sonne tout le temps a way
that they say a besoin qu'on vous
appelle toute la journée cette maladie
terrible touche ça comme leur sexe
sont couchés ils maintiennent la bouche
ils parlent à leurs chiens sont tout le
temps face et un terrible des outils
signes extérieurs de détresse ah bravo
ça pourrit la vie
le pire c'est grandir seul vivre seul ou
vieillir seul vieillir seul à
le pire c'est de ne plus pouvoir toucher
la personne avec qui vous vivez ou de
plus vouloir la toucher a de plus
pouvoir
problème de m6 est une négation noir et
c'est une illusion qui tenait devant la
réalité de la vie
le pire quand on est plaqué le pire
c'est de l'apprendre par une lettre un
coup de fil ou par quelqu'un reçoit
m'est arrivé quelquefois mais je savais
avant donc que j'aurais on ne m'apprend
rien généralement dans ce domaine le
pire c'est d'apprendre que dieu n'existe
pas ou qu'il existe mais que ce n'est
pas le vôtre
qu'il existe et que c'est pas bien
jamel
[Applaudissements]
je suis prêt le pire cadeau de noël
qu'on pourrait vous faire
des vacances avec le pape ou des
vacances avec berlusconi nonaka meeddat
au mont tauch et tu m'a pas donné
beaucoup de choix là ses cauchemars
maintenant ses propres devant mais si
vraiment hélico pour aller choisir
quand il pas
plutôt que mieux chez le pape que chez
berlusconi et berlusconi ne fait peur en
ce moment aux italiens parce qu'ils
possèdent toutes les chaînes de
télévision les siennes plus les chaînes
gouvernementale puisqu'il est premier
ministre il fait voter des lois pour
enterrer ses magouilles précédente il a
déclaré que la civilisation occidentale
était supérieur à la civilisation
musulmane
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas peur en
italie de voir arriver un régime non
démocratique avec à sa tête ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un doute chez soft non
c'est une question mes proches oui c'est
vrai que ça me préoccupe enfin taire la
teste en fait atome est comme à la fois
des professionnels à une tête qui a tout
à fait la forme de celle de mussolini
la pire des situations
dans laquelle vous pourriez vous trouvez
interview cauchemar ça serait d'avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu du bon vin mais
pas tire bouchon ou une gonzesse super
mais pas de préservatif
aïe aïe
ce qui me plaît le plus sarah bey avait
eu la bonne ce serait d'avoir une femme
qu'on est pressé relative avec un
préservatif
[Applaudissements]
alors le pire sous gros c'est un
portable qui sonne tout le temps ou un
portable qui sonne jamais
à
la pire ce serait d'avoir le téléphone
portable
le pire c'est de grandir celle de vivre
seul ou de vieillir seul
y avoir de toutes façons on est toujours
celle way
le pire ça serait de plus pouvoir
toucher votre maîtresse ou au contraire
de plus vouloir la toucher
ainsi cours maintenon vont assurément ne
plus vouloir toucher ce maîtresse le
pire c'est d'être blasé très jeunes ou
insatisfaits à l'âge de la retraite la
cause
pire
à mon sens c'est de n'être vieux
comme beaucoup de gens
pensent être vivant mais qui en fait
sont morts est
le pire pour l'humanité vous pensez
qu'il est à venir
qu'il est derrière nous ou que ça peut
pas être pire qu'aujourd'hui non verano
quand je m'auto petitrenaud il va y
avoir encore pour les choses bien pires
assurément
le pire c'est d'apprendre qu'on ait
quitté par une lettre par un coup de
téléphone ou par quelqu'un d'autre
elle n'a ni besoin de me téléphoner n'a
ni besoin de m'envoyer une lettre ni de
me faire dire par quelqu'un d'autre
parce que moi je le sens qu'elles mc et
déjà six mois avant
[Applaudissements]
ronaldinho
gal elmaleh le pire des accidents
conjugaux vous faire surprendre par
votre femme avec votre maîtresse
n'importe quoi surprendre votre flamme
avec votre meilleure amie ou surprendre
votre femme et votre maîtresse ensemble
c'est sûr prendre ma femme avec mon
meilleur ami ouais c'est ça sert ips ben
oui c'est oui parce que j'en perds deux
d'un coup
et là on dira pas le nom du meilleur ami
de la femme de gad elmaleh on dira juste
ça
la magie
cette commission est réputé pour sa
discrétion exactement donc on donne pas
les normal que des indices voilà alors
le pire cadeau qu'on puisse vous faire
une perceuse sans fil un abonnement un
club de gym huit jours de vacances avec
vincent perrot
un abonnement avait un club de gym parce
que déjà avec un seul abonnement je vous
croise dans les vestiaires ouais c'est
vrai alors avec deux je crains le pire
[Applaudissements]
la pire situation au quotidien avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu une carte bleue
mais pas le code une fille super mais
pas de préservatif une fille super mais
pas le fond quoi
votre pires désillusions gad elmaleh ça
serait d'apprendre qu'il y a quelqu'un
dans casimir
que thierry la fronde avait une
chaussette dans son collant ou que
goldorak et doublé pour les cascades que
goldorak et doublé pour les cascades
parce que ça c'est
dégueulasse le pire ce serait
d'apprendre que dieu n'existe pas ou
qu'il existe mais que ce n'est pas le
vôtre
c'est que c'est que dieu n'existe pas
parce que je pense pas que le dieu que
quand quelle je crois parce que je crois
en dieu soit que le mien non mais c'est
qu'il n'existe pas passé avec le nombre
de mecs qui se sont fait sauter en l'air
et quand tu es des gens pour dieu ouais
c'est pas très sympa s'il existera le
pire c'est de grandir salle de vivre
seul ou de mourir seul de mourir seul
parce que je l' ai déjà vécu
et je dois dire que c'est assez duré
ouais vraiment ouais parce que de
grandir seul je les fait vivre seul je
l' ai déjà vécu mourir seul plus jamais
[Musique]
joey starr
vous vivez ou dans vos cauchemars je
fais pas de cauchemar ça
n'en fait pas t'as pas un autre truc à
interview chez moi mais non mais elle
est bien c'est une interview à dire je
fais des cauchemars et est déjà là ce
soir pour toi c'est un cauchemar je suis
un cauchemar dont votre copine elle vous
trompe avec qui dans vos cauchemars
j'apprécie beaucoup ranca me trompe il a
les cheveux oui nantais cauchemar est il
a tabassé crois que c'est vrai
un peu con toi
c'est quoi votre métier de jouer dans
vos cauchemars
c'est une horde mouche j'écoutais quoi
comme musique dans vos cauchemars stomy
bugzy
que ça bien
c'est qui qui est en tête du top 50 dans
vos cauchemars
ministère amer
vous avez peur de quoi dans vos
cauchemars iam
vous mourrez commandant au cauchemar en
écoutant du sommet mais aussi nous
montrer à quel âge dans vos cauchemars à
l'âge des cerises et
vous découvrez quoi sur vous dans vos
cauchemars
que je ressemble à pacy
vous fait attaquer par quel genre
d'animal dans vos cauchemars un
sarcellois
ressemble à quoi l'humanité dans vos
cauchemars c'est parce que ça me ferait
de pire cauchemar ouais vous ayez sur
quel plateau télé dans vos cauchemars tu
as je fais drucker tout à l'heure
c'était pas mal alors c'était pas mal il
est onze mois
[Musique]
pierre vous ressembler à quoi dans vos
cauchemars je suis à l'école et le prof
me dis c'est pas parce que vous êtes
célèbre qu'il faut pas faire votre voix
et je me réveille en sueur
sans avoir fait d'être va évidemment
c'est qui votre femme dans vos
cauchemars ma mère
à l'eau froide
présents la république dans vos
cauchemars ceux qui comme moi oui
franchement je serais pas quoi vous de
la france vous acceptez quel film dans
vos cauchemars en faire un film de cul
puisque je
vous fait quoi comme critique dans vos
cauchemars ok
maintenant c'est que je mets en haut
mais le chemin
vous vivez au caire dans le cauchemar
[Applaudissements]
ouste en dix endroits d'un cauchemar une
île déserte où un petit village enfin là
où il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde n'est
pas de bars de nuit et tout ça m'arrête
je suis pas que ça
vous écoutez quoi comme musique dans le
cauchemar du rap ouais mais pas
seulement enfin du rap et de la house
va seulement dans mes cauchemars dans
les boîtes de nuit où je veux aussi quoi
vous avez peur de quoi dans vos
cauchemars pierre
g j'ai peur qu'on me pardonne pas oui
mais mes erreurs ouais vous mourrez
commandant vos cauchemars un jour j'ai
rêvé que je mourrais comment as tu un
nom de noyer du futur une voiture et je
les loyers
mais en fait la voiture était dans un
lac est pas des pantins de conduire
on découvre quoi sur vous dans vos
cauchemars je suis amoureux coup
vous fait attaquer par quel animal dans
vos cauchemars pierre
or je suis fatigué un jour par une loi
non s'est il passé
vous faites chargé par une oie s'est
passé c'est mauvais je sais j'en ai la
campagne non mais c'est vrai en même
temps les oies c'est un avantage c'est
que c'est le meilleur chien de garde loi
oui et puis on peut la bouffe et à
prêcher un groupe nous fait trop penser
que cette interview n'est qu'un
cauchemar qui va bientôt s'arrêter
pierre tuvéri à cette adresse intervient
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou